[Musik]
und willkommen bei einer neuen folge von
unserem viele podcast hallo jörg freut
mich dass wir uns wieder unterhalten
können heute geht es um das thema des
bösen
für mich als kind kann ich festhalten
dass es ganz klare unterscheidung
zwischen gut und böse für mich war
irgendwie wenn ich star wars oder herr
der ringe angeschaut habe ganz klar
sowie eine seite sind die bösen und die
anderen sind die guten wurde auch so
kommuniziert aber irgendwann kommt man
so auf den punkt wo man sagt sie
vielleicht stimmt das nicht so ganz
landet dann dabei dass man feststellt
bei dieser frage nach gut und böse geht
es um verschiedene werte vielleicht
inzwischen prinzipien die man
argumentiert motivationsgrund und
relativierte so ein bisschen aber dann
mit der beschäftigung der philosophie
fällt mir halt auf das ist ja dann doch
im moralischen anscheinend weiterhin
diesen begriff gibt und die frage ist
aber mich was ist das böse und ist es
eher so abhanden seines guten oder gibt
es ist es das gegenteil davon
aus dem grund jetzt an dicht die frage
nicht was ja zwei bücher veröffentlicht
die können ja auch verlinken
wahrscheinlich und die frau war mit was
für ein problem haben jetzt eigentlich
zu tun was das ist das schwierige daran
ja marcel du hast es eigentlich schon
völlig richtig gesagt das böse ist sehr
viel deutet also es gibt einmal so diese
ansicht das gute und das böse sind so
prinzipien
man redet ja auch von dem guten und dem
bösen als ob es so ein gegenstand wäre
das eine dunkle macht die da so
existiert und das ist natürlich ein sehr
problematische auffassung von bösen weil
wir dazu neigen das zu übertragen auf
gewisse menschen sogar oder völker oder
gesellschaften
da bin ich als jugendlicher unter darf
raiders ungenau also böse mächte aber
eben das problematische ist dass es
nicht nur eben
abstrakten oder fantastischen
ästhetischen sind eben häufig denn auch
in der wirklichkeit verwendung findet
naja ich darf nur an die rede von der
achse des bösen erinnern
das halte ich für sehr gefährlich nah
weil wir damit ganze gesellschaften
völker oder auch menschen stigmatisieren
und zum bloßen objekt zu machen und das
sollten wir nicht machen also wenn wir
vom bösen sprechen dann wie ich meine
immer in einem kritischen sinne und zwar
so dass wir damit nicht gegenstände
meinen sondern letztendlich handlungen
oder noch genauer motiv also gut oder
böse würde ich sagen sind nur unsere
motivationen unsere maximen würde kannst
sagen die dann zu handlungen führen also
von einer bestimmten art dann genau also
wir haben eben gute maximen würde könnte
sagen gute motive die unseren handlung
zugrunde liegen oder eben böse es gibt
immer zwei möglichkeiten
ja und dass die qualifizierung würde
dann eben darin bestehen dass man
aufgrund einer einzigen handlungen die
ganze person oder kultur oder nation
oder sozusagen komplett als so böse
sieht und das böse daten der genau darin
verortet und nicht in diesem einzelne
handlung sting das wäre der punkt genau
also es ist geht einfach darum dass wir
eine sehr kritische haltung zu diesen
begriffen einnehmen und ist man es hat
viele leute dazu gebracht zu sagen dass
wir diese begriffe gar nicht mehr
verwenden sollten gut und böse und zum
des bösen und ich glaube eben wir können
diesen begriff schon noch verwenden aber
eben nur in einem kritischen sinne dass
und irgendwie würde das aussehen also du
bist man hört man fragt oder sehr oft
von von dass wir eine freiheit zum guten
aber auch eine freiheits- und bösen
haben
siehst du daran irgendwie ein vorteil
oder sind wir nicht vielleicht manchmal
auch einfach opfer eines bösen triebes
vielleicht sogar ja also guter punkt
stichwort trieb wir machen oben rechts
zu unserem interview wird dieses thema
ein dazu würde ich sagen wenn wir jetzt
opfer eines triebel sind und ihm
unterliegen dann sind wir darin
eigentlich nicht mehr frei und dann
können wir auch streng genommen nicht
mehr vom bösen sprechen also wir sind
nur dann böse wenn wir darin frei waren
und jetzt ist natürlich die frage können
wir uns wirklich bewusst willentlich für
das böse entscheiden ja wie wie sieht's
mit einem mord aus also das ist eine
ganz ganz spannende frage
jemand der jemand anderem ermordet sagt
er sich jetzt oder sie sich jetzt ich
möchte ihn oder sie jetzt ermorden
einfach so aus lust und laune solche
menschen gibt es aber häufig sind solche
menschen die das aus einem gewissen
sadismus heraus machen psychisch krank
also die würden dann häufig im vor
gericht wahrscheinlich eine mildere
strafe bekommen oder vielleicht sogar
eine psychiatrie eingewiesen werden
hingegen die meisten menschen die jemand
anderen ermorden die würden jetzt nicht
sagen nur ich ermorden jetzt weil ich in
der morgen will sondern die würden sich
selbst sagen ich habe gute gründe diesen
menschen zu töten eigentliche morde ich
ihnen gar nicht so eigentlich tue ich
nur das was gut und gerecht ist oder es
könnte so ein strategischer notwendiger
schritt für ein angeblich höheres gut
sein genau also in den seltensten fällen
werden leute getötet jetzt ermordet und
die täter sagen sich oder wird sind sich
dessen bewusst dass jemanden im orden
sondern in der regel konstruieren sich
die mörder so eine scheinwelt so eine
illusion eine rechtfertigung strategie
die sie sich zusammen legen und vor der
erscheint dann dieser mord als
gerechtfertigt aber ich finde gerade
interessant dass du sozusagen es heißt
die diejenigen die sich ganz klar für
das töten ermorden entscheidung wie es
vielleicht sogar eine art lust oder so
verspüren dies zu tun werden sind sie
sind psychisch krank und werden
wie eingesperrt und diejenigen die sich
im konstrukt gedankenkonstrukt gebilde
irgendwie erschaffen indem sie das
rechtfertigen sind irgendwie wersen ich
finde da nicht verrückt
also ich denke so ein gedankenkonstrukt
zu bilden ist eine ur menschliche
angelegenheit also wir leben alle in
illusionen mehr oder weniger und sind
immer wieder aufs neue gefordert diese
illusionen mit der wirklichkeit in eine
deckung zu bringen also uns korrigieren
zu lassen
jetzt gehört sicherlich unsere
überlebensstrategie hinzu dass wir uns
gewissen illusion hingeben
im kleinen sag ich mal gefährlich wird
es dann aber wenn diese illusion so
mächtig werden dass sie uns zu
handlungen motivieren oder uns
handlungen erlauben die dann zur
verletzung andere personen führen und da
müssen wir dann wirklich aufpassen
häufig sind solche illusionen ideologien
erkennen wir genug aus dem zwanzigsten
jahrhundert und auch noch im 21
jahrhundert haben wir jede menge
ideologien die dazu führen dass menschen
glauben andere menschen töten zu dürfen
aus vermeintlich guten motiven ja das
ist verrückt weil das so ein bisschen
natürlich paradox ist es dann auch ein
böses was aus bösen gründen geschieht
wenn wir bisher nur von bösen handlungen
die aus scheinbar guten gründen gemacht
werden also ich glaube eben du hast es
angesprochen der schein ist das ganz
zentrale also wir tauschen uns selbst es
geht um selbsttäuschung ich glaube dass
das der hauptgrund des bösen ist ich
glaube dass in allerwenigsten fällen
wird das böse wirklich um des bösen
willen tun dass ich jetzt weiß dass es
böse und jetzt tools obwohl ich weiß
dass es böse ist und ich tue es auch
gerade deswegen weil es böse ist sowas
gibts auch zum beispiel gibt es davon
augustinus der jetzt ja wirklich sehr
christlich war von dem gibt es da ein
beispiel wo er beschreibt wie er als
junger eine birne stahl sitzt keinen
ordner aber eine birne nur um sie zu
stehlen er hat die birne gar nicht
gegessen wollte die birne nicht weil sie
gut schmeckt so nur weil es verboten war
diese bühne zu stehen
dh das böse übt eine gewisse faszination
auf uns aus
und jetzt kann man sich fragen was liegt
hinter diesem reiz des bösen dieser
faszination des bösen ich glaube
dahinter liegt unsere freiheit das wir
uns darin selbst mächtig erscheinen wir
können uns über grenzen hinweg setzen
die uns von außen gegeben sind ich
glaube es hängt damit zusammen dass wir
uns selbst im bösen auch eine ganz
intensive weise erfahren
ja also dann haben wir jetzt bald
irgendwie immer noch die frage wie
erkennen wir dass böse weil ob der mord
es ist sagen wir sind ganz klar darauf
gepolt dass morgen böse ist und das ist
auch so eine natürliche intuition
erscheinen aber auch bei anderen
handlungen irgendwie nicht so schlimm
erscheinen auch eine intuition zu haben
woher kommt die wie können wir überhaupt
begründen dass etwas böse ist ja das ist
eine spannende frage wiederum es gibt da
auch häufig relativistische auffassung
die sagen ja was gut und was böse ist
das hängt doch von der kultur ab das
sieht jeder anders und ich glaube dass
es nicht so ist aber ich glaube schon
dass wir uns da sehr anstrengen müssen
das was böse ist zu begründen
total krass weil ich mein nämlich über
www sprechen darüber dass das menschen
ermordet werden und und ich finde
einfach so auch manchen seminaren die
wir hatten genau den diskussionen das
ist so das geht so richtig an die wurzel
finde ich das geht so krass an die
wurzel dass man einfach wenn mir niemand
das gut argumentieren kann hat man das
gefühl dass es schwierig ist zu
begründen dass jetzt ich nehme wieder
das beispiel menschen töten halt böse
ist das ist schwierig finde ich weil da
kann jemand kommen und sagen aus den
gründen ist es ist nicht böse ja also es
steht und fällt damit ob man den mensch
seine absolute würde zugestehen wir
haben die im grundgesetz verankert jetzt
kann man natürlich aber auch das
wiederum in frage stellen wir
philosophinnen philosophen sollen ja
alles immer auch hinterfragen
aber ich glaube schon dass es auch gute
philosophische gründe gibt für diese
absolute würde und zwar hängt die eben
zum beispiel damit zusammen dass wir
frei wesen sind ich komme jetzt wieder
auf dem gifte freiheit zu sprechen
das heißt dass wir uns selbst ziele
setzen und die dann auch verfolgen
können und in dem wir jemand anderen
körperlich beeinträchtigen oder auch in
das leben nehmen nehmen wir ihm dieses
sehr besondere vermögen der freiheit und
das scheint mir so ein grundprinzip des
bösen zu sein dass man die freiheit des
anderen einschränkt dann ist man im
gegenzug gesagt seine eigene freiheit
überbetont und über die freiheit des
anderen spült und das ist glaube ich
auch im zug des bösen natürlich wenn man
das dann als prinzip irgendwie sieht
auch hypothetisch seine eigene freiheit
wiederum einschränkt weil man durch das
böse handeln legitimiert das andere auch
so handeln genau also im eigentlich
genau betrachtet sind wir im bösen wenn
wir grenzen überschreiten gar nicht so
frei wie wir glauben sondern wir
verstricken uns in bestimmte
lügengebäude zum beispiel wir
verstricken uns in abhängigkeiten am wir
verlassen unsere domäne und begeben uns
in andere bereiche wo wir nicht mehr zu
hause sind das heißt das böse ist
eigentlich am anfang vielleicht sehr
leicht erscheint am anfang sehr leicht
möglich zu sein aber auf lange frist ist
es sehr sehr strapaziös und es eben der
gegensatz zum guten im guten ruhen wir
irgendwie hirn heim guten haben mir so
eine harmonie und dem bösen haben wir
nie harmonie da haben wir immer eine
gewisse spannung zerrissenheit die
vielleicht spannend ist interessant ist
aber auf lange frist sehr sehr
gefährlich und unangenehm werden kann
so erfordert ist im prinzip ja auch in
gewisser weise
mut die freiheit zum guten zu ergreifen
und bestimmte dinge aufzugeben die man
im bösen hätte könnte man das so fest
dass ich denke durchaus auf den ersten
blick sieht es so aus als ob wir im
guten auf etwas verzichten müssten
nämlich über seine auf sonne überspannte
konzeption von freiheit indem wir uns in
gewissen grenzen fügen aber auf lange
frist hingesehen aufs ganze gesehen
waren wir damit wesentlich besser
eben wegen dieser harmonie wegen dieses
gleichgewichts und wegen dieser
fehlenden verstrickung in zum beispiel
lügengebäude deren konsequenzen gegen
bösen gar nicht absehen können und
würdest du zum schluss noch sagen das
böse und gute weniger von der frage was
man macht abhängt sondern wie man es
macht also aus welchen gründen man das
mach ich glaube dass es ganz
entscheidend ist es geht immer um die
gesinnung also um die motivation hinter
der handlung wir sehen der handlung
selbst nicht an ob sie aus guten oder
bösen motiven geschah das heißt wir
müssen immer nach den gründen fragen die
zur handlung geführt haben nur auf die
ebene der gründe können wir entscheiden
ob sie gut oder böse ist diese handlung
ja dann vielen dank für dieses interview
york als ausblick oder reflexion für die
zuhörer will ich noch eine sache setzen
und zwar in einer komplett
kontrollierten und überwachten
gesellschaft indem man sieht was man
macht es ist natürlich schwierig
aufgrund es was zu erkennen dass eine
tat böse oder gut war weil man immer den
menschen braucht der vor ort redet in
einer gerichtsprozess oder persönlich um
die gründe dafür zu erfahren und das ist
halt in der gesellschaft wo alles
gefilmt wird alles dokumentiert wird
sagen keine voraussetzung dass man
erkennt was gut oder böse ist nur
aufgrund der daten sondern man braucht
auch immer also eine gewisse erklärung
genauer als eine völlige objektivierung
auch durch diese internetdaten bringt
uns nicht unbedingt weiter hinsichtlich
der frage was jetzt
oder böse ist allerdings kann man
durchaus durch suchanfragen in dem man
somit h daten auswertet gewisse
rückschlüsse ziehen also ich glaube du
hast einen guten punkt angesprochen
diese digitalisierung wir haben dazu
auch ein video gemacht oben rechts die
führt dazu dass sich die frage nach dem
was gut oder böse ist auf eine neue art
stellt und die wird die sache noch sehr
spannend machen vielen dank dann bis zu
seiner nächsten folge und tschüss
[Musik]